This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The new film Green Book is rolling out across the country. I have not seen the film, so I can't speak to its merits or its shortcomings. But while people are possibly being introduced to the concept of the Green Book for the first time, we thought we'd release this story from a few years ago about the origin and significance of the Green Book, the Negro Motorist Travel Guide to the Segregated US. It's an amazing story and one of my old-time favorites. As a special bonus in this episode, we'll also be playing a Green Book story from Nate Domeo of the Memory Palace. Nate had coincidentally written his Memory Palace episode called Open Road about the Green Book and we both released them without having heard the other,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。新电影《绿皮书》正在全国上映。我还没看过这部电影，所以无法评价它的优缺点。但考虑到人们可能第一次接触到“绿皮书”这个概念，我们决定发布几年前制作的这期节目，讲述《绿皮书》的起源与意义——这本针对美国种族隔离时期的黑人驾车旅行指南。这是一个了不起的故事，也是我一直以来最喜欢的节目之一。作为本期的特别福利，我们还将播放来自《Memory Palace》的内特·迪梅奥（Nate Dimeo）讲述的关于《绿皮书》的故事。巧合的是，内特也写了一集关于《绿皮书》的《Memory Palace》，名为《开放之路》（Open Road），我们两人在互不知情的情况下分别发布了各自的作品。
and I think hearing them one after another is a real treat. It highlights our shows, similarities and differences in our approach to a subject. It makes me very happy to share them together today. I hope you like it. This is the American dream of freedom on wheels. An automotive age, traveling on time-saving superhighways. The 1940s, 50s and 60s were the golden age of road travel. Cars had become cheap and roomy enough to carry families comfortably for hundreds of miles. The Interstate Highway System had started to connect the country's smaller roads into a vast nationwide network.
我认为将它们连在一起听是一种真正的享受。这突显了我们节目在处理同一主题时的相似之处与不同之处。今天能把它们放在一起分享，我感到非常高兴。希望你们喜欢。这是轮子上的美国自由梦。在汽车时代，人们行驶在节省时间的超级公路上。20世纪40、50和60年代是公路旅行的黄金时代。汽车变得既便宜又宽敞，足以让家庭舒适地行驶数百英里。州际公路系统开始将全国较小的道路连接成一个庞大的全国性网络。
Finally, tourists could make their way from New York to California, with the windows down and the wind in their hair, seeing the grandeur of America along the way. We have become the nation on wheels, with more motorized mobility than ever dreamed of before. But of course, this freedom and mobility wasn't available to everyone. That's our senior editor and splash of cold water to Laney Hall. Because in 1956, the year that federal funding made the interstate highway system possible,
终于，游客们可以从纽约开车前往加利福尼亚，摇下车窗，感受风吹过头发，沿途欣赏美国的壮丽景色。我们已经成为一个轮子上的国家，拥有前所未有的机动性。但当然，这种自由和流动性并非人人都能享有。这是我们的资深编辑、负责泼冷水的德莱尼·霍尔（Laney Hall）。因为在1956年，即联邦政府拨款使州际公路系统成为可能的那一年，
Jim Crow was still the law of the land. In the south, racial segregation was enforced by law and had been since shortly after reconstruction. In many parts of the north, the codes were enforced in practice. And these codes could make a simple road trip really complicated for black travelers. How is this? Is that a good level? Is all you picking me up well there? This is Curtis Graves. Okay, my name is Curtis Graves and I was born in 1938, so I'm a little older than most of the people who are listening to this. Curtis would eventually become a Texas state representative,
“吉姆·克劳法”仍然是当地的法律。在南方，种族隔离由法律强制执行，这种情况自重建时期后不久就开始了。在北方的许多地方，这些准则在实践中被执行。而这些准则会让黑人旅行者的一次简单公路旅行变得非常复杂。这是什么？这个音量可以吗？你听得清楚吗？这是柯蒂斯·格雷夫斯（Curtis Graves）。好的，我叫柯蒂斯·格雷夫斯，我出生于1938年，所以我比大多数听众都要年长一些。柯蒂斯后来成为了德克萨斯州的州议员，
and then he'd go on to work at NASA, and then he'd become a photographer. But as a kid, he grew up in the segregated south. And for many years, his parents tried to shield him from that reality. I've often said that both my mother and father were the best liars that I knew. For instance, we sat in the back of the bus because it was cooler there. We rode in the front of the train because you could get off quicker. We sat upstairs in the movie because you had better seats in the upstairs. Of course, that ruse couldn't last.
之后他去了NASA工作，后来又成为了一名摄影师。但作为孩子，他在种族隔离的南方长大。多年来，他的父母一直试图让他远离那种现实。我常说，我的父母是我认识的人里最会撒谎的。例如，我们坐在公交车后排，因为那里凉快。我们坐在火车前排，因为下车更快。我们坐在电影院楼上，因为楼上的座位更好。当然，这种把戏不可能一直奏效。
And by the time Curtis was a college senior in Houston, Texas, in the mid-1950s, he was fully aware of what it meant to be a black person living under Jim Crow. There's one experience in particular that stands out in his mind. He was just 21 years old and getting ready to drive to a college meeting in Waco about three hours northwest of Houston. He'd agreed to take a couple of acquaintances. They happened to be white women. I said to myself, I might be in for some difficult times here, but you know, I had to sew John. To get to Waco, Curtis had to drive through a stretch of East Texas that was notorious in those decades for racial violence. Oh yeah those communities were pretty bad. Around
到20世纪50年代中期，柯蒂斯在德克萨斯州休斯顿读大四时，他已经完全意识到作为一名生活在“吉姆·克劳法”下的黑人意味着什么。有一段经历让他记忆犹新。当时他才21岁，准备开车去休斯顿西北约三小时车程的韦科参加一个大学会议。他答应带上两个熟人。她们恰好是白人女性。我对自己说，我可能要遇到些麻烦了，但我必须送她们去。为了到达韦科，柯蒂斯必须穿过德克萨斯州东部的一段路，那段路在当时以种族暴力而臭名昭著。哦，是的，那些社区非常糟糕。大约在
dusk the travelers got hungry so they pulled over at a roadside diner. As soon as we got in the front door the guy said, ah, sorry but you can't come in here. We don't serve black people at all. So the three of them went back outside and Curtis devised a plan. They'd try another restaurant right across the street. I said to them, the two of you go in, get a table. And after you're seated and the waiter or waitress comes up to you, tell them that you have a boy that's driving you,
黄昏时分，旅行者们饿了，于是他们在路边的一家餐馆停了下来。我们刚进前门，那个人就说，啊，抱歉，你们不能进来。我们根本不接待黑人。于是他们三个人回到外面，柯蒂斯想出了一个计划。他们尝试街对面的另一家餐馆。我对她们说，你们两个进去，找张桌子。等你们坐下，服务员过来时，告诉他们你们有个司机在开车，
and that you want to know whether he can bring him in to eat. So the women walked inside and they asked the waitress if Curtis could come inside to join them. And the lady said, of course, no problem at all. So as long as I was that boy and their driver, I could eat with them at a table in a restaurant, but if I were equal to them, I could not. This kind of humiliation on the road was routine and had been going on for decades.
想问问能不能让他进来一起吃饭。于是女士们走进餐馆，问服务员柯蒂斯是否可以进来加入她们。那位女士说，当然，没问题。所以，只要我是那个“男孩”和她们的司机，我就能和她们坐在餐馆里吃饭；但如果我和她们平等，我就不能。这种在路上的羞辱是家常便饭，而且已经持续了几十年。
Many people wrote into the NAACP around this time, describing experiences just like curtices. To hold a make-in-surn, before starting our recent vacation trip to several Eastern states, I would like to report an incident occurring on January 1st at a golf service station in Macon, Georgia. My wife and I went to the restaurants to refresh ourselves, then found a vacant table ten minutes past and no one came to service. I keep. He informed me that the restroom for the color was in the back.
当时许多人写信给全国有色人种协进会（NAACP），描述了和柯蒂斯类似的经历。在开始我们最近去几个东部州的度假旅行之前，我想报告1月1日在佐治亚州梅肯市一家海湾服务站发生的事件。我和妻子去餐馆休息，发现有一张空桌子，十分钟过去了，没有人来服务。我询问后，他告诉我，有色人种的洗手间在后面。
It seems to me dealers should not be permitted to sell gas and oil and not provide these comforts for us also. Some travelers would drive all night instead of trying to find lodging in an unfamiliar and possibly dangerous town. They'd pack picnics so they didn't have to stop for food. Some people would even carry portable toilets in the trunks of their cars, knowing that there was a good chance they'd be turned away from roadside restrooms. But since 1936, a guy named Victor Hugo Green had been trying to help with some
在我看来，经销商不应该被允许销售汽油和机油，却不为我们提供这些便利。有些旅行者会整夜开车，而不是试图在陌生且可能危险的城镇寻找住宿。他们会打包野餐，这样就不必停下来吃饭。有些人甚至会在汽车后备箱里携带便携式马桶，因为他们知道自己很有可能被路边的洗手间拒之门外。但自1936年以来，一个名叫维克多·雨果·格林（Victor Hugo Green）的人一直在试图解决其中一些
of these problems, to make life easier for thousands of black motorists. State by state, he'd been putting together a travel guide with listings of restaurants, hotels, and service stations that would welcome African-American travelers. He called it the Negro Motorist Green Book.ist Green Book, the Green Book for short. Victor Green, who died in 1960, lived in Harlem, New York during the height of the Harlem Renaissance. His apartment was not far from Duke Ellington's.
问题，让成千上万黑人驾车者的生活变得更轻松。他州复一州地整理出一份旅行指南，列出了欢迎非裔美国旅行者的餐馆、酒店和服务站。他称之为《黑人驾车者绿皮书》，简称《绿皮书》。维克多·格林于1960年去世，他在哈莱姆文艺复兴鼎盛时期居住在纽约哈莱姆区。他的公寓离艾灵顿公爵（Duke Ellington）的公寓不远。
His office would eventually be situated near Smalls Paradise, a famous nightclub. Victor didn't have the most obvious background for starting a travel guide. He didn't work in tourism, he wasn't a writer, he was a mailman in Hackensack, New Jersey. But he kept hearing stories about discrimination on the road. So he would go do his route in Hackensack, New Jersey, come back home and work on a green book at night, compiling these addresses, typing them up and putting them in a book form. This is Calvin Alexander Ramsey, playwright, author, and filmmaker.
他的办公室后来设在著名的夜总会“小天堂”（Smalls Paradise）附近。维克多并没有创办旅行指南的明显背景。他不从事旅游业，也不是作家，他只是新泽西州哈肯萨克的一名邮递员。但他不断听到关于路上歧视的故事。所以他会在哈肯萨克完成他的投递路线，回到家后晚上编写《绿皮书》，汇编这些地址，打字并整理成书。这是卡尔文·亚历山大·拉姆齐（Calvin Alexander Ramsey），剧作家、作家和电影制作人。
And years ago, Calvin started researching the history of the green book. He learned that the green book wasn't really the first guide of its kind. In fact, Victor may have gotten the idea from Jewish travelers. Because the Jewish community was also having issues on the open road with a lot of the places saying restricted, and that was a code word for Gentiles only. When Victor published his first green book, it just covered New York. And he heard from around the country from other carriers and other people saying we really need this nationwide. But it wasn't that easy to gather information from across the country from other carriers and other people saying we really need this nationwide.
多年前，卡尔文开始研究《绿皮书》的历史。他了解到《绿皮书》并不是同类指南中的第一本。事实上，维克多可能是从犹太旅行者那里得到的灵感。因为犹太社区在公路上也遇到了很多地方写着“限制性”的问题，那是“仅限外邦人”的代号。当维克多出版第一本《绿皮书》时，它只涵盖了纽约。他从全国各地的其他邮递员和其他人那里听说，他们真的需要全国性的指南。但当时从全国各地收集信息并不容易。
But it wasn't that easy to gather information from across the country back then. Long-distance phone calls were expensive. And that, Calvin says, is when Victor Green realized that being a mailman was his secret superpower. There were African-American let-a-carriers all over the United States at this time. We're talking about 1936. And so he knew about, you know, the relationships that the male men have with their homeowners or apartment dwellers delivering their male. So just like today, the male man is part of the community. So Calvin says Victor tapped into this network, spreading the word about his guide through the National Alliance of Postal and Federal federal employees, a letter carrier union. Calvin says postal workers across the country scouted potential green book locations in their cities and towns. He says some even asked
但当时从全国各地收集信息并不容易。长途电话很贵。卡尔文说，就在那时，维克多·格林意识到身为邮递员是他的秘密武器。当时全美各地都有非裔美国邮递员。那是1936年。他了解邮递员与房主或公寓住户之间投递邮件的关系。就像今天一样，邮递员是社区的一部分。所以卡尔文说，维克多利用了这个网络，通过全国邮政和联邦雇员联盟（一个邮递员工会）传播关于他指南的消息。卡尔文说，全国各地的邮政工作人员在他们所在的城市和城镇搜寻潜在的《绿皮书》地点。他说有些人甚至询问
families they delivered to if they'd be open to hosting travelers in their homes. And if they agreed, then they would send the information to Victor Green in Harlem. Victor was able to get a feel for us of let it carriers who are all over the country, who acquired materials and names and addresses and businesses for him. Wherever they were, the black male man, you had a Green Book salesman or recruiter. Pretty quickly, the Green Book caught on. Businesses, many black owned, began getting in touch with Victor, hoping to advertise and hoping to be listed. Black newspapers signed on as sponsors. Victor eventually retired from his job as a letter carrier
他们投递邮件的家庭是否愿意在家里接待旅行者。如果他们同意，他们就会把信息发送给哈莱姆区的维克多·格林。维克多能够通过遍布全国的邮递员网络获取信息，他们为他收集了材料、姓名、地址和企业信息。无论他们在哪里，只要有黑人邮递员，就有《绿皮书》的推销员或招募员。很快，《绿皮书》就流行起来了。许多黑人拥有的企业开始联系维克多，希望打广告并被列入名录。黑人报纸也签约成为赞助商。维克多最终从邮递员的工作中退休，
and started working on the guide full time. He even opened an affiliated travel agency that helped tourists arrange trips. But still, there was the challenge full time. He even opened an affiliated travel agency that helped tourist arrange trips. But still there was the challenge of distribution. How to get the guide into the hands of travelers who needed it. That happened in a few ways. The United States travel bureau signed on to help out and then there were the more informal networks. Well churches, Pullman Portters, the Urban League, the NWCP, the Masonic lodges. There was a very wide, very distribution process in place for these green books. And there was an important corporate. There's a smile for every mile at the SO sign.
开始全职从事指南的工作。他甚至开设了一家附属旅行社，帮助游客安排行程。但仍然存在分销的挑战。如何将指南送到需要的旅行者手中。这通过几种方式实现。美国旅游局签约提供帮助，还有一些更非正式的网络。教堂、普尔曼搬运工、城市联盟、全国有色人种协进会、共济会会所。这些《绿皮书》有一套非常广泛的分销流程。还有一个重要的企业合作伙伴。在埃索（Esso）标志下，每一英里都有一个微笑。
The SSO makes your car go! And be mortering! SO, also known as Standard Oil, and now known as ExxonMobil, was one of the few oil companies back then that actively pursued black customers. They franchised their stations to African-American operators, and they had a black representative on staff, James Billboard Jackson, who helped place green books in many of those stations, as well as the White Own ones. S.O. may have done this out of a sense of fairness and equality.
埃索让你的车跑起来！埃索（Esso），也被称为标准石油公司，现在称为埃克森美孚，是当时少数几家积极争取黑人客户的石油公司之一。他们将加油站特许经营给非裔美国经营者，并且在员工中有一位黑人代表詹姆斯·比尔伯德·杰克逊（James Billboard Jackson），他帮助将《绿皮书》放置在许多这些加油站以及白人拥有的加油站中。埃索这样做可能是出于公平和平等的意识。
John DeRocquefeller, who founded Standard Oil in 1870, had married into a family of abolitionists who were part of the Underground Railroad, and he'd voted for Abraham Lincoln back in the day. But SO probably did it for another reason too. Money, honey. It has to do with money. Remember Curtis, who had the crappy experience driving across East Texas? His dad operated one of the first black-owned SO associations in New Orleans where Curtis was born and raised.
1870年创立标准石油公司的约翰·D·洛克菲勒（John D. Rockefeller）娶了一个废奴主义者家庭的女儿，他们是地下铁路的一部分，而且他当年还投票支持过亚伯拉罕·林肯。但埃索这样做可能还有另一个原因。钱，亲爱的。这和钱有关。还记得那个在德克萨斯州东部开车经历糟糕的柯蒂斯吗？他的父亲在柯蒂斯出生和长大的新奥尔良经营着第一批黑人拥有的埃索加油站之一。
It was called Bootsy and Buddies. The economic logic of stocking the green book was pretty simple, he says. If you want black people to buy your fuel, why don't you give them an opportunity to see that they can travel and find places to stay while they're on the road traveling. So Curtis's dad kept a shelf of green books for his customers. You know, somebody came in and said, buddy, I'm thinking about taking a trip to Chicago, my dad would say, well, do you know where to stop between here in Chicago?
它叫“靴子与伙伴”（Bootsy and Buddies）。他说，储备《绿皮书》的经济逻辑很简单。如果你想让黑人购买你的燃料，为什么不给他们一个机会，让他们看到自己可以在路上旅行并找到住宿的地方呢？所以柯蒂斯的父亲为他的顾客保留了一架《绿皮书》。你知道，如果有人进来问，伙计，我正考虑去芝加哥旅行，我父亲会说，好吧，你知道从这里到芝加哥哪里可以停吗？
And the person would say, no, he said, well, here. The Green Book will tell you. And it gave you a sense of security. And so the Green Book came to cover listings in all 50 states and even some locations in Canada, the Caribbean, and Mexico. They printed about 15,000 copies a year. Victor Green had changed travel for thousands of African-American tourists.
那个人会说，不知道。他说，好吧，给你。这本《绿皮书》会告诉你。它给了你一种安全感。于是《绿皮书》涵盖了所有50个州的列表，甚至包括加拿大、加勒比地区和墨西哥的一些地点。他们每年印刷约15,000册。维克多·格林改变了成千上万非裔美国游客的旅行方式。
He wrote in a 1956 introduction to the guide. Now, things are different. The Negro traveler can depend on the Green Book for all the information he wants. This guide has made traveling more popular without encountering embarrassing situations. But as the civil rights struggle continued, some people began to question the value of the Green Book. Black people many of them began to feel that this was accommodating to Jim Crow. Susan Rue is a professor of history at Brigham Young University, and she says that the Green Book began to seem a little out of step with the Times.
他在1956年指南的序言中写道：现在，情况不同了。黑人旅行者可以依靠《绿皮书》获取他想要的所有信息。这本指南让旅行变得更受欢迎，而不会遇到尴尬的情况。但随着民权斗争的继续，一些人开始质疑《绿皮书》的价值。许多黑人开始觉得这是在向“吉姆·克劳法”妥协。苏珊·鲁（Susan Rue）是杨百翰大学的历史学教授，她说《绿皮书》开始显得有点跟不上时代了。
It rarely took on an overtly political tone, especially in its early days. And there were actually other black travel guides published around the same time that did. One called travel guide, for instance. Travel guide listed where the NAACP chapters were in each city. They were much more attuned with civil rights, much more political tone, eventually the NAACP
它在早期很少采取公开的政治立场。事实上，当时还出版了其他黑人旅行指南，它们确实采取了这种立场。例如，有一本叫《旅行指南》（Travel Guide）的书。它列出了每个城市全国有色人种协进会分会的位置。它们与民权运动更加协调，政治色彩更浓。最终，全国有色人种协进会
made it clear. And the NAACP said, what we're striving for, we're striving for integration. And so that's their stand. And the NAACP built a lot of their push for the 1964 Civil Rights Act, which outlawed discrimination based on race, and ended Jim Crow around this idea of total integration. In fact, when the NAACP testified during the debate over the bill, they drew on all those letters they'd received about discrimination on the road. They appealed to that vision of the iconic family road trip of the freedom to explore America by car. Roy Wilkins, the executive secretary of the NAACP, spoke before the Senate's Commerce Committee in 1963. As soon as Congress gets out, they're all gonna head into their station wagons and go back to their home district.
明确表达了立场。全国有色人种协进会表示，我们所争取的是融合。这就是他们的立场。全国有色人种协进会围绕这种完全融合的理念，推动了1964年《民权法案》的通过，该法案取缔了基于种族的歧视，并终结了“吉姆·克劳法”。事实上，当全国有色人种协进会在关于该法案的辩论中作证时，他们利用了收到的所有关于路上歧视的信件。他们诉诸于那种标志性的家庭公路旅行愿景，即开车探索美国的自由。全国有色人种协进会执行秘书罗伊·威尔金斯（Roy Wilkins）于1963年在参议院商业委员会前发言。国会一休会，他们都会开着旅行车回到各自的选区。
It's July in Washington. It's really hot. We'll concess the Senate to imagine what it might be like to travel as a black person. Would you like me to read what Roy Wachon said? How far do you drive each day? Where and under what conditions can you and your family eat? Where can they use a restroom?
那是七月的华盛顿。天气非常热。我们请参议院想象一下作为一名黑人旅行会是什么样子。你想让我读读罗伊·威尔金斯说了什么吗？你每天开车多远？你和你的家人在哪里、在什么条件下可以吃饭？他们可以在哪里使用洗手间？
Can you stop driving after a reasonable day behind the wheel? Or must you drive until you reach a city where relatives or friends will accommodate you and yours for the night? Will your children be denied a soft drink or an ice cream con because they are not white? So he's appealing to them and at the most basic level of their own love for their
你能在开车一段时间后停下来吗？还是必须一直开到有亲戚或朋友能为你和你的家人提供住宿的城市？你的孩子会因为不是白人而被拒绝购买软饮料或冰淇淋蛋筒吗？所以他是在以最基本的层面诉诸他们对自己
own family. And Susan thinks this may have been one of the things that helped pass the bill. By framing the narrative of civil rights as a family travel narrative, they were able to convince the senators to vote for the bill. In 1964, President Lyndon Johnson signed the bill into law. The Congress passes the most sweeping civil rights bill ever to be written into the law, and thus reaffirms the conception of equality for all men that began with Lincoln and the Civil War 100 years ago. The Negro won his freedom then. He wins his dignity now. The Civil Rights struggle was not over then,
家人的爱。苏珊认为这可能是帮助法案通过的原因之一。通过将民权叙事构建为家庭旅行叙事，他们成功说服了参议员们投票支持该法案。1964年，林登·约翰逊总统签署了该法案，使其成为法律。国会通过了有史以来最广泛的民权法案，从而重申了100年前林肯和内战开始时对所有人平等的构想。黑人那时赢得了自由。他现在赢得了尊严。民权斗争当时并没有结束，
and it's still not over today. But for Victor Green, it became clear at some point that his Green Book had a limited shelf life. He wrote in the introduction to one of his guides. There will be a day sometime in the near future. This guide will not have to be published. That is when we, as a race, will have equal opportunities and privileges in the United States. In sure enough, two years after the Civil Rights Act passed,
今天也还没有结束。但对于维克多·格林来说，在某个时刻，他清楚地意识到他的《绿皮书》寿命有限。他在其中一本指南的序言中写道：在不久的将来，总有一天，这本指南将不再需要出版。那就是我们作为一个种族在美国拥有平等机会和特权的时候。果然，在《民权法案》通过两年后，
the Green Book published its last edition. So actually, could you just describe where we are? We're at the public library, downtown, the central branch in Los Angeles, and we're down in the bowels for floors down underground in the history and genealogy department. You have a stack of books there in front of you. What are those? They are green books. They're just little jewels.
《绿皮书》出版了最后一版。那么，你能描述一下我们现在在哪里吗？我们在洛杉矶市中心的公共图书馆，中央分馆，我们在地下四层的历史和家谱部门。你面前有一叠书。那些是什么？它们是《绿皮书》。它们就像小小的宝石。
I mean, I just buzzed with this kind of good energy that I just feel like, oh my God, they're actually here. It's amazing, it's amazing. Kandace Taylor is a photographer and a cultural documentarian. The guide she's holding are small, maybe eight inches by five inches. They have green covers, each with a different destination featured, and there are pages and pages of listings inside.
我的意思是，我被这种美好的能量所感染，我感觉，天哪，它们真的在这里。太神奇了，太神奇了。坎迪斯·泰勒（Kandace Taylor）是一位摄影师和文化纪录片制作人。她手里拿着的指南很小，大约8英寸乘5英寸。它们有绿色的封面，每一本都有不同的目的地，里面有页复一页的列表。
Let me see. There were beauty parlors, barbershops, tailors, taverns, there were nightclubs. It was really a social network. It was anything you might want to do in that town and the resources that were available to you. Kandace has been traveling the country documenting old Green Book locations from California to Oklahoma to New Mexico. Many establishments are now run by people who don't know much if anything about the police's history. by people who don't know much if anything about the police's history. Some of the buildings are gone and what's left is just an empty lot or a patch of grass. Even these original copies of the guide are rare now.
让我看看。有美容院、理发店、裁缝店、酒馆，还有夜总会。这真的是一个社交网络。这是你在那个城镇可能想做的任何事情以及你可以利用的资源。坎迪斯一直在全国各地旅行，记录从加利福尼亚到俄克拉荷马再到新墨西哥州的旧《绿皮书》地点。许多场所现在由对这些地方的历史知之甚少甚至一无所知的人经营。有些建筑已经消失了，剩下的只是一块空地或一片草地。即使是这些原始版本的指南现在也很稀有。
This Smithsonian bought one at auction recently. For $22,500. Wow. Yes. So look in your, if you're listening to this and you know your parents, you know, lived during Jim Crow, look in your adics and see you might have a, you know, 20 plus thousand dollar guide. You never know. Twenty thousand dollars is a lot of money. But back in 1936, when the green book first appeared
史密森尼学会最近在拍卖会上买了一本。花了22,500美元。哇。是的。所以如果你正在听这个节目，并且知道你的父母在“吉姆·克劳法”时期生活过，去你的阁楼里看看，你可能有一本价值两万多美元的指南。你永远不知道。两万美元是一大笔钱。但在1936年，《绿皮书》首次出现时，
and could be purchased for 25 cents by the travelers who needed it the most, it was arguably worth even more. Thanks to backstory with the American History Guides for the recordings of the letters to the NAACP, read by Alicia Floyd, Stephen Tulliver, and Leslie Telephario, and Al Letson, who played the part of Victor Green. Thanks also to Orlando Gonzalez at the National Association of Letter Carriers and Jackie Moore at the National Alliance of Postal and Federal Employees. We have another take on the Green Book from Nate Dimaio's the memory palace that you will not want to miss. Stay with us.
对于最需要它的旅行者来说，它只需25美分，可以说它的价值甚至更高。感谢《Backstory with the American History Guys》提供给全国有色人种协进会的信件录音，由艾丽西亚·弗洛伊德（Alicia Floyd）、斯蒂芬·塔利弗（Stephen Tulliver）、莱斯利·泰勒法里奥（Leslie Telephario）和扮演维克多·格林的阿尔·莱森（Al Letson）朗读。也感谢全国邮递员协会的奥兰多·冈萨雷斯（Orlando Gonzalez）和全国邮政和联邦雇员联盟的杰基·摩尔（Jackie Moore）。我们还有内特·迪梅奥的《Memory Palace》对《绿皮书》的另一种解读，你绝对不想错过。请继续收听。
The memory palace is a long time member of the radiotopia collective in a huge inspiration in the creation of 99% of visible. If you don't already listen, you've made a huge mistake, my friend, and you're about to hear why. Nate is the best writer in podcasting, and the memory palace is a gem. This is the memory palace. I'm Nate Demet. The couple in the cover are ready for the road. He's square-jawed and strapping. She's
《Memory Palace》是Radiotopia集体的一名长期成员，也是《99% Invisible》创作的巨大灵感来源。如果你还没听过，那你可就犯了大错，我的朋友，你马上就会知道原因。内特是播客界最好的作家，《Memory Palace》是一颗宝石。这是《Memory Palace》。我是内特·迪梅奥。封面上的那对夫妇准备好上路了。他下巴方正，身材魁梧。她
pretty, smiling-wide. He carries both of their suitcases because it's 1948 and he's a gentleman. In his dress like one, top-curred pocket square, Fedora had a jaunty angle. She's got her hair done, wavelette curls beneath her Sunday vest hat. The couple pictured there on the cover of the 1948 edition of the Negro Motorist Green Book, with a very picture of a particular kind of African-American aspiration at mid-century.
漂亮，笑容灿烂。他提着他们两个人的手提箱，因为那是1948年，他是一位绅士。他的穿着也像一位绅士，口袋里插着方巾，软呢帽斜戴着，显得很时髦。她做了头发，波浪卷发在周日的帽子下若隐若现。那对出现在1948年版《黑人驾车者绿皮书》封面上的夫妇，正是世纪中叶非裔美国人某种抱负的写照。
In somewhere in those suitcases, or in her clutch, or in the glove box in the big old dash of the Pontiac or the Packard, is a book, a slim paperback, 30-40 pages, a guide for African-American travelers, 30, 40 pages, a guide for African American travelers, specifically for the lucky, the rare few who own to carve back then. And there they are on the cover, this handsome couple, drawn in black and white, walking off from their suburban home to look for America. Comforted by that guidebook, published each year since 1936 by the Victor E. Green Company of Harlem, in order to give, it says,
在那些手提箱里的某个地方，或者在她的手包里，或者在庞蒂亚克或帕卡德汽车那巨大的仪表盘手套箱里，有一本书，一本薄薄的平装书，30到40页，一本为非裔美国旅行者准备的指南，专门为那些当时有幸拥有汽车的少数人准备的。封面上的那对俊男靓女，用黑白线条勾勒出来，正走出郊区的家去寻找美国。他们得到了那本指南的慰藉，该指南自1936年起由哈莱姆区的维克多·E·格林公司每年出版，目的是为了给，书中写道，
the Negro Traveler, information that will keep him from running into difficulties, embarrassments, and other understatements. The couple will use it to navigate the post-war, pre-highway United States, to keep themselves safe and alive, in their own car, free from the cruelties of segregated public transportation, of colored only waiting rooms, of backs of buses. They'll be in the front seat of their own car, their own gas pedal, their own steering wheel, on the open road, the radio on it, searching for their song, their music, in the open air.
黑人旅行者提供信息，使他免于陷入困境、尴尬和其他轻描淡写的麻烦。这对夫妇将用它来导航战后、高速公路时代之前的美国，以确保他们自己安全地活着，开着自己的车，远离种族隔离的公共交通、仅限有色人种的候车室、公交车后排的残酷。他们将坐在自己汽车的前座，踩着自己的油门，握着自己的方向盘，行驶在开放的公路上，收音机开着，寻找他们的歌，他们的音乐，在开阔的空气中。
You might catch a voice coming through the static, a rhythm carried on invisible waves from some rooftop transmitter and decatur or Memphis, and falling away as some skyline disappears in the rear view. And then coming in clear and strong now, as they come out of the trees, as the road rises through the Alligain easer, as they round to bend, and the air is warm to the windows, and warm on their arms, and the light is warm and tangerine, flashing on the surface of the snake river, or the Nishinabatna, or the Laksa Hatchin, driving off to, who knows, the grand tea-tons, Liberty Hall, the Finger Lakes, Beale Street, Pinkett Desert, in their own car.
你可能会在静电中捕捉到一个声音，一种节奏，通过迪凯特或孟菲斯某个屋顶发射器发出的无形波浪传播，随着天际线在后视镜中消失而减弱。然后，当他们走出树林，当道路穿过阿勒格尼山脉，当他们转过弯道时，声音变得清晰而有力，空气温暖地吹进车窗，温暖着他们的手臂，光线温暖而呈橘黄色，闪烁在蛇河、尼什纳博特纳河或拉卡萨哈奇河的表面，开车前往谁知道哪里，大提顿国家公园、自由厅、五指湖、比尔街、平克特沙漠，开着他们自己的车。
Somewhere right then, South Paradise and Dean Moriarty were on the road. Somewhere right then, an ad-man was showing an executive, a pitch that would put a car in every garage. Some auto company lobbyist was showing some senator just where the freeways would run one day, through which unwanted neighborhoods, telling him how those freeways would free us all. How we'd road trip, see the USA and our Chevrolet, look for adventure in whatever comes our way. Milwaukee to Minneapolis in 4. our way. Milwaukee to Minneapolis in four and a half hours. Coast to coast in four and a half days. A nation transformed. A people on the move. It's great cities. It's natural wonders. It's amber waves.
就在那时，萨尔·帕拉迪斯（Sal Paradise）和迪恩·莫里亚蒂（Dean Moriarty）正在路上。就在那时，一位广告人正在向高管展示一个能让每家每户都拥有一辆车的推销方案。某家汽车公司的游说者正在向某位参议员展示高速公路未来将如何运行，穿过哪些不受欢迎的社区，告诉他这些高速公路将如何解放我们所有人。我们将如何公路旅行，在我们的雪佛兰里看美国，在我们的路上寻找冒险。密尔沃基到明尼阿波利斯只需四个半小时。横跨全国只需四天半。一个国家被改变了。一个民族在移动。它伟大的城市。它的自然奇观。它的琥珀色波浪。
It's purple majesty. All within reach. Unlimited possibilities of the open road. We're the couple on the cover drove right then, is the Sun Hungla, as their stations started to fuzz at the edges. The book said they could go to Oakland, stay at the Warren Hotel on 6th, eat at the Crescent in the Frederick, Maryland. See the Grand Canyon? Get a drink at Gill's Grill in Elizabeth Town.
它的紫色威严。一切触手可及。开放公路的无限可能。那对封面上的夫妇当时正开着车，当他们的电台开始出现杂音时。书上说他们可以去奥克兰，住在第六街的沃伦酒店，在马里兰州弗雷德里克的克雷森特餐厅吃饭。去看大峡谷？在伊丽莎白镇的吉尔烧烤店喝一杯。
But they shouldn't stop in Shelby Montana. There were no Negroes there. They should probably say they're delivering the cardo its white owners if they get pulled over outside Lafayette. Should steer clear of whole cities altogether. The sundown towns that were all white. By law. By nightfall.
但他们不应该在蒙大拿州的谢尔比停留。那里没有黑人。如果他们在拉斐特郊外被拦下，他们可能应该说他们是把车送到白人车主那里。应该完全避开整个城市。那些全白人的“日落镇”。根据法律。到天黑时。
There will be a day the Negro motorist Green Book says in the near future when it won't have to be published. But until that time there was the book and the couple there in its cover. As the sun goes down and the road stretches out and summer bugs flash white in the headlights and the signal fades, probably out for good this time. And they hope the gas holds out till Topeka. There's a place called Powers, the green book says. They can get service there.
《黑人驾车者绿皮书》写道，在不久的将来，总有一天它将不再需要出版。但在那之前，还有这本书和封面上那对夫妇。当太阳下山，道路延伸，夏天的虫子在车灯中闪烁着白光，信号减弱，这次可能真的彻底消失了。他们希望汽油能撑到托皮卡。绿皮书说有一个叫鲍尔斯的地方。他们可以在那里获得服务。
And then they should be able to make it to Wichita. They packed in a food, they wouldn't have to risk stopping to eat. It might be better just to stay in Topeka by the time they get there. Book says there's a hotel there where they should be okay. It might just be better. We play it safe. And they drove on. And the moon rose over in open field.
然后他们应该能到达威奇托。他们带了食物，这样就不必冒险停下来吃饭。也许最好还是留在托皮卡，等他们到达那里时。书上说那里有一家酒店，他们应该没问题。也许最好还是安全第一。他们继续开车。月亮升起在开阔的田野上。
Another take on the green book from the memory palace. If you somehow neglected subscribing to the memory palace here to 4, I actually kind of envy you because you have 134 episodes of short, beautiful, arresting history stories waiting for you. It's a life-changing show. This should be your Thanksgiving holiday entertainment, just shotgunning the memory palace episodes. Nate DeMoeo has been making the memory palace for 10 years and it represents the best
这是《Memory Palace》对《绿皮书》的另一种解读。如果你不知何故还没订阅《Memory Palace》，我其实有点羡慕你，因为有134集简短、优美、引人入胜的历史故事在等着你。这是一个改变生活的节目。这应该是你感恩节假期的娱乐节目，一口气看完《Memory Palace》的所有剧集。内特·迪梅奥制作《Memory Palace》已经10年了，它代表了
of the medium, so subscribe, download all the episodes, tell your friends, I'd love to see it reach 10 times as many people it deserves it. I'll have a link in the show notes. 99% of Usible was produced this week by Delaney Hall. The rest of the team is Senior Producer Katie Mingle, Digital Director Kurt Colstad, Avery Truffleman, Sharifusif, Emmett Fitzgerald Sean Riel, Vivian Lee, Joe Rosenberg, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco. Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Vivian Lee, Joe Rosenberg, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown,
这种媒介的精华，所以订阅吧，下载所有剧集，告诉你的朋友，我很乐意看到它触及它应得的10倍多的人群。我会在节目说明中放一个链接。本周的《99% Invisible》由德莱尼·霍尔制作。团队其他成员包括资深制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、谢里夫·尤西夫（Sharif Youssef）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心电台街制作。
Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi org or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want over 300 other episodes of 99% In plus links and pictures of the green book. Look no further than our beautiful, beautiful website. It's 99pi.org. Radio tilp you. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》是来自PRX的Radiotopia的创始成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上可以找到更多信息。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99piorg，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注。但如果你想要《99% Invisible》的其他300多集节目，以及关于《绿皮书》的链接和图片，请访问我们美丽的网站。网址是99pi.org。来自PRX的Radiotopia。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。